-You're Smiler.
-Yeah, I'm like a really intense
office manager.
-Now, did you --
How did you get into character
for Smiler, the emoji?
-That's a great question, Seth.
-Thank you.
-I work really hard [Chuckles]
at smiling a lot.
-Uh-huh. Did you actually smile
while you were talking?
-I actually did have to.
That's not -- That's not a lie.
-Okay.
-I found that
it's really hard for me.
-Smiling is hard for you
or talking while you're smiling?
-Talking through smiling
is intense
because there's a lot of --
I guess I'm a real downer
when I talk.
I guess I kind of
talk like this.
-Yeah, that. That sounds like
the Maya I know.
-That's what sounds like me,
right?
-Yeah, that's you.
-What are you doing?
-Yeah. That's the Maya I know.
-It's like Eeyore.
-Yeah. Right.
-Like, when you talk to me,
it's like you're talking to
Eeyore, right?
-Yeah.
-That makes sense.
Smiler is more like the muscles
are activated up here.
And I'm just not
that kind of person.
-No, that is
a very unnatural face.
-That looks horrible.
That looks terrifying.
Which is actually good, 'cause
she's a little terrifying.
-Yeah, but have you --
Does it -- So the muscles.
Would you do an hour at a time,
two hours at a time?
-Yeah, you got to take breaks.
You got to drink a lot of water.
You got to sometimes,
like, stretch.
-Okay, interesting.
[ Laughter ]
Stretch this part
or the whole rep?
-Just this part.
-Just those, yeah.
-Just these muscles.
-Yeah.
Would you just, like, rest one
on the side of the table?
-Yeah, you rest one on the table
like this.
-Yep.
-And then you do like a push-up.
-Gotcha, yeah, that makes sense.
[ Laughter ]
-It feels really good.
-You have four children.
-Yes.
-Are your children going to see
"The Emoji Movie"?
-Oh, they're pretty stoked.
-Okay, gotcha.
-My 3-year-old obviously
doesn't have a phone
because that would make me
a monster.
-Yeah.
-But she knows what emojis --
Everybody knows what emojis are.
Today is World Emoji Day.
-Today is World Emoji Day?
-Today is the day, guys.
-Wow, amazing.
-Yeah.
-Was that a thing
before the movie?
-No.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
So it was kind of like
a nice little tie-in.
-They were like,
"We've got an idea.
Let's capitalize on this."
-Have your kids seen your films?
-They have, but I'll be honest.
I'm a little old-fashioned.
Like, Pearl is now 11.
She's my oldest.
And she complains all the time
that all of her friends
have seen "Bridesmaids"
except for her.
But I feel like, you know,
there's some, like, racy --
It's not bad,
but it's more like language.
Like, maybe the first scene
is a little racy.
But, like, she knows what
pooping is, which is fine.
But I have to say now --
-I will say, you can know what
pooping is, and still,
if you were her mom,
it would be very traumatic to
see how you poop in that movie.
-You might be right.
I feel like
I'm making a smart choice.
But then the system failed
because then we thought
it would be a good idea to show
them Austin Powers 1 and 2.
So, I was, like, hanging out
with the kids.
Everyone's like, "Oh, no."
But, like, we were hanging out
and someone was talking
and Pearl just brought up
a penis pump.
I was like, "How do you know
what a penis pump is?"
She was like, "Austin Powers!"
[ Laughter ]
Good job, Mom.
-Yeah, that's not a kid's movie.
-Nope.
-Your 3-year-old --
Ours is coming up on two.
Is it a cute age, three?
Do you like -- Are they verbal?
-Oh, my God, they're so -- Are
you getting the cute verbals?
-We're getting a little --
the beginnings of words, yes.
-Does he have, like, words that
you can't stop making him say?
-No. It's more like
everything is "that."
He's just constantly "Da! Da!"
-Love that so much.
-Yeah.
He's like a baby tour guide.
[ Laughter ]
The minute he wakes up,
you'd say, "How are you?"
He goes, "Da! Da!"
You're like, "Okay, let's just
get on with it."
-It's only going to get better
from here on out.
We had --
Like I said, Pearl is now 11.
She's my oldest,
but for years, she called --
We used to go to my dad's house
and get in the Jacuzzi,
and she called it "cachuzzi."
And so, like,
to this day I'm like,
"Let's get in the cachuzzi."
And she'll be like,
"Mom, it's a Jacuzzi."
[ Laughter ]
No, it's not.
-Oh, so you don't want to give
up the baby words.
-I don't want to give it up.
-See, this is
an interesting argument
my wife and I are having,
because my family
did not give up the baby words.
We just kept them.
-That's correct.
-So, to this day,
I and my brother call breakfast,
"breffix."
And so when I say it to Ashe,
my wife is pointing out,
"No, you can't teach him
the baby word."
He has to teach us
the baby words. We can't --
-You're like,
"That does not compute."
-And my thing was,
maybe if we use "breffix,"
his baby word for it
will be breakfast.
[ Laughter ]
-That is so damn adorable.
-Yeah.
-I love "breakfixed."
-Breffix.
-You say "breffix"?
-Breffix. B-R-E-F-F-I-X.
-Were you from
the South side of Chicago?
-Yeah. Breffix. "We're gonna go
out and get some breffix."
-Where my breffix?